okay bet yes um I don't want to say
anymore you know I just I don't even
know what to say anymore I'm playing
[ __ ] adult games cuz the only thing
that interests me anymore you know aside
from coffee and paying taxes this is all
I have left
let's do this
I'm sure oh my god she's beautiful oh I
guess the legends are true you do exist
yes I take it
she'll be been laid next time let me see
it what the [ __ ] if you want this gig
you gotta listen to directions we both
know I'm doing you a solid by letting
you manage my girls I mean let's keep it
a hundred here this is a closest you're
getting two female interaction right now
okay payment enough and it will be since
that's the only payment you're getting
okay any more time I'll start you out
with one of our fresh constants
Oh which one of these girl catches your
eye let me see here and you say I'll be
the judge Oh Tiffany Nick yeah okay
10 hits Ted saw Tina uh you gotta go for
this dick ass when I say that no matter
who you pay okay oh boy a shout-out our
break up in the girls section for me
will ya
okay all you gotta do to employ her and
dragged her from the girls section to
the open position on the studio bars to
the right they can't touch us why don't
we get a new employee try to a quick
camp show you do bark for the building
in the southwest corner of the city
that's to do
to ease the cast he earns from jamming
gets deposited at the studio so you have
to pull it out if you want to spend it
okay and a positive city out how do I
you got a click up on that building go
ahead
you do the work oh why $5 clearly this
girl is new to Cammy I mean look it's a
start again but if we're gonna make it
in this we need fans well hats relief
let's have a legit shoot done drag her
over to the photo studio kay okay
similar to cam shows we have to collect
the new fans fantastic alright so here's
the deal with I'm sure I don't need to
explain what a fetish is to a sick freak
like you but it's important to go over
it cashews are so good I'll show you
what I need crack open the fan section
real quick
here you can see how oh dick ass broken
down by fetish looks like she had a
small following before we hired her fans
of a particular fetish we'll only watch
girls who can satisfy that desire people
are picky about their porn like that so
if you had a bunch of dudes who are into
black chicks that's not going to help an
asian girl at all you get it I got it
photo shoot she's only going to interest
new fans who match one of her fetishes
you can always see which fetishes a girl
satisfies by checking her profile I'll
show you see her fetishes are listed
right left ana and together naturally
support a couple by default
her current fan count which is based on
our fetishes is down here the more fans
she has the more money she'll earn kamek
let's have our girl to another
thank our Buffett building while a girl
is there and we'll rush the activity so
it's completed faster it's pretty useful
we'll kick off the show is normal drop
her off at the camp studio
now click the [ __ ] out of that building
I'll keep the contraband so you can get
an idea of how it works okay look at
that that's some damn fine clicking you
can also click and hold if you want
let's give that a try
collect the cash from the camp studio by
clicking and holding - so far so good
there's a model agency in town that's
bound to be ok and one of our girls in
there undercover to show our studio I'm
sure she can line up some solid
prospects it's better than you going in
there and creeping them out oh and we
ain't employing [ __ ] unless we open up a
new position we gotta invest in growing
the business you know ok why don't you
pull up the invest there are a lot of
aspects of business you can invest in
here to expand operations improve
functions and maximize revenue in order
to employ a second girl we need to
invest in staffing I'm too important to
click things are rad moving up in the
work and big but don't forget you work
for me ok ok I think I get what's going
on the more fans the better
there are dick dick trophies in it for
you - I made them myself
so remember 21 days the caucus I highly
recommend starting now get back to work
okay what oh [ __ ] I forgot something
but we're not running off slave labor
here we do have to pay these lovely
ladies I'll show you how we do payroll
do we escape the payroll section shows a
list of employer dollars what there
Curtis if we have the cash on hit but be
careful because the payroll will
automatically process every night at
midnight even if we can't afford it
Vaughn just say no sir
protip don't forget to invest in
inventory okay okay now we're doing that
we're doing it when you're looking at
new girls to recruit there are a couple
things to keep it what the music note
represents her talent level the higher
the talent level is the more money she
earns per fan wild the little ball
represents but higher talent and style
levels do come out of context so you
better be if you want more deep lasting
okay well we're going huge taps engine
Chalet here on this one cuz she doesn't
smoke a drink
how do I up I'll try not to screw up her
but give it a shot
yes what yes yes yes all right so what
do you do you just keep on doing this
how do I invest more okay why not well
I'll make it so much money Camp Camp
Camp Camp Camp Camp yeah
Camp Camp camp can't the [ __ ] out of
here come on a lot more Cammy more
camming more Cammy more camping more
camming okay so I was starting on energy
- what is that like 32 what is this six
drinks that down
Capacete Oh
that's just how fast you get the [ __ ] up
let's [ __ ] come on fetch more fans thank
you you did great honey you did great
honey we'll give it a shot
Wow I can make them both do that that's
the same oh [ __ ] okay each time a girl
doesn't it
if a girl reaches 100 percent stress
that's it fortunately there's a rope the
more stressed out sheet
all right stress poise more more MORE I
need more money more money okay hello
stressed she got 59:40 every 15 minutes
can't call it up
okay let's do it baby
mm-hmm yeah great honey
yeah a great [ __ ] she got their ticket
shall we - hello Fairlie okay let's see
how rich we could get these [ __ ]
faster faster faster
I need more money more money
shit's getting [ __ ] dangerous levels
come on come on fetch can't they get
that money can't that sweet sweet money
okay she'd get a little [ __ ] up all
right guys five just taking a while what
the [ __ ]
okay here we go a lot faster a lot
faster okay get the [ __ ] back in there
get the [ __ ] back in there
faster faster faster yes yes more money
more money
get the [ __ ] back in there can't can't
can't can't can't can't shut up get
shutters good okay this is doing good
I'm pretty good pep you know I'm pretty
good that's okay the rest of my shot
hardware why not
[Laughter]
[Music]
how are you okay so okay fine we'll do
that just loose [ __ ] money come on
come on car
we're gonna need another girl I think
it's like that dick ass I like it why
not sure why not
how do I get like a toys and stuff for
them tarik recruit teen fit yeah
frequent [ __ ] now I'm going to wonder
does a [ __ ] smoke [ __ ] flat-chest
addicted Asian
Tenten holy [ __ ] this one's really
[ __ ] up f [ __ ] it okay we're getting
little crazy
being naked on the internet isn't as
easy as it sounds you got to put some
effort into that [ __ ]
yeah I agree and if you bring a girl
over here when you collect a point here
just remember okay thank you
what the [ __ ] is that too stressed out
[Music]
[Music]
give it a shot more money more money
okay okay
come on how do I get three okay yes yes
more money more money
I'm a day three I feel pretty good I
think she saw the last six we're running
a little low on cigarettes and booze a
chef a lot of these camphor a girl who's
most but so if it looks like this is a
liquor so and this is okay you're
killing me right we need to make some
sticks if you stay in the red it's
nothing personal
sure how am i canned more money so many
steaks that I get I gotta get a lotta
money in that [ __ ] a sixties why is
the money changing can little tricky
give her that money Bama give her that
money all right all stressed out let's
get some more fans [ __ ]
please tell me please tell me can I get
them stuff oh sure
[ __ ] I might as well just [ __ ] do
this kind of suck dick for [ __ ] it 1000
I think it's worth it though I think
it's a good plan I'm good these girls
have it work - a little lungs I need it
they need it badly
98 very sad I can't get some sex that
how much this cost is 197 sick [ __ ]
free anymore sex okay good good good
good
I need more money
how dare you
after all I've done for you after all
I've [ __ ] done for you [ __ ] okay
books [ __ ] hang Lilian I'm not to
fire that [ __ ] oh my god LOI you're
[ __ ] sick and we dry how do i fire
her she's so [ __ ] up but she's also so
hot so like what's like to know like
JJ's ass like well changes what would
you tell Jett these girls are gonna be
working like [ __ ] dogs I guess okay
[ __ ] any more money few more [ __ ] I'm
getting me broke
[Music]
like fire this [ __ ] [ __ ] I need more
500 okay I went to Russia come on
too stressed y'all better hurry
[ __ ] I just get more chicks in
no [ __ ] I don't know what to do here
[ __ ] it we need another person calm
pitch yes we know
I just need all the money I can get you
know what's up our ass I don't need ice
hell Labs is that I'm saying
[Laughter]
[Music]
not too bad I can't get the [ __ ] back in
there can't can't can't can't can't
can't can't okay Jesus I do not this is
the same I'm working these people like
[ __ ] slice this is bad
oh no Michael I'm so pro get me my money
[ __ ] can't make my money money here why
not
holy [ __ ] how do you see me fans oh [ __ ]
that one I need six we need those sweet
things okay oh [ __ ]
will do what's the points leave it to me
here why not yeah but go in baseball
takes like ten years okay what do you
feel like teens and love those teens how
do I fire people
[ __ ] any more money he take it to 500
okay let's see yeah it's insane
okay please don't chop okay no accessory
from here you can trip you can see which
accessory okay this is one person what
the [ __ ] is this
no I don't want that American
accessories
combats yeah spa we gotta get you [ __ ]
please kill me okay okay
AML fetish reported sometimes
okay so I have to active it right
[ __ ] activated there we go
mmm I need money they're gonna let me
try any second come on bench too
stressed out come on [ __ ] work your
magic [ __ ] I don't know money I'm gonna
be insanely into debt make it that mind
we get that mind we get that money that
she's gonna [ __ ] kill me
oh [ __ ] get the [ __ ] in there Disko
better [ __ ] again i [ __ ] [ __ ]
actually went got a toy or something you
get our toy here we get her a little toy
because you spend that as well growing
now what toy do you adore I need to know
we sure why did it get her so much
energy
cotton okay [ __ ] [ __ ] okay books books
books thank God give it a shot
okay maybe even that finally AK it's
[ __ ] a forchette cigarettes armor let
bat uh-huh I mean like in this game
they're pretty bad in real life okay
girl let's go let's go let's go let's go
make out money that I make that money
you gotta make us I can't raclette the
money fast enough
next pay more money [ __ ] I think I'm
willing to pay like 200 then get the
[ __ ] back in there why not take fetish
[Music]
Oh
25% 25% guess get this who's the one
that's like always stressed out
give me that money fatty give me that
money you know how much I love that
money I'll show it the [ __ ] knows that
I'm the way keeps doing that okay let's
see here this girl's [ __ ] stressed
off [ __ ] out her
I gotta get that cash when I get that
cash money
yeah signs are going to negatives no 122
that is so good
oh my god okay any more toys what is
this [ __ ] half as much pay
I'm Diane our she's really stressed out
appreciate it
the [ __ ] am i doing okay okay I just
[ __ ] wasted it okay yeah get the [ __ ]
in there make me my money get the [ __ ]
in there I just love caring [ __ ] go get
your sex love camming okay get the [ __ ]
outta here come on eat more money they
should do it they should do it yes yes
I'm talking about they're all [ __ ]
relaxing Lee's sucking [ __ ] come on
cam shout come on
I just came [ __ ] all day just be so
high
not too bad
holy [ __ ] okay let me just [ __ ] you get
the cigarette things over with baby baby
yeah okay yeah [ __ ] a we need some
like good [ __ ] I need more fans kids are
[ __ ] there okay
water sports finish not you bad photo
shoot six
[Music]
and
[ __ ] it egg get the [ __ ] in there [ __ ]
get to [ __ ] work more money [ __ ]
negative okay now I gotta make some more
changes I got another one
250
capacity 500 [ __ ] a why not mine is
loud will do need more fans I set them
all to the photo shoot I get some more
money you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah just [ __ ] in there give it
a shot
done literally I can't okay
to get these fans real quick so what
happens when I get like all these fans
well Frank more money to stressed out
37 cash 62 cash holy [ __ ] more money
that you get this [ __ ] out of here can
you sketch okay shake it good
might as well and I'll betcha
might as well I got your sex just make
her casa get six not to run after
shopping
I'll bet kept after work
[Music]
check it those six I should probably
look for a goal to see 500
you
I think I should get 5,000 no way how do
use the Bravo oh [ __ ] okay
I thought that was like a one-time use
thing okay and how do I go faster all
right I should buy just buy that 1000
thing
[ __ ] this taken forever shame or [ __ ] I
don't even know I thought it'd be sure
to get these can barrels
yes it's harder than I thought hmm yeah
[ __ ] it we'll do it a lot of money here
what [ __ ] now there's more to do
combat speed this up a little bit I need
more money a lot of ladies outside Jesus
all right come on come on
taste dress down [ __ ] [ __ ] get off
sex get those eggs no problem why aren't
you camming okay I think I can get that
1000 you make it easy for you I put
together the promo section you know the
drill open up that window for me okay
is a list of all the sites currently
offering ad space it refreshes every day
and each site caters to
[Music]
by the way if you [ __ ] egg who's a
squirter
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
actually get more fans fans even
important I don't know
that was your nail but I don't know 49
fans [ __ ] they are sucking my dick dry
their suck my dick try I'll kill you
[ __ ]
I need more fans she's fresh had a weed
okay it's sign oh it's a lot of money
okay
uh yeah lot of just [ __ ] holding
what's this [ __ ] John said I said I
gotta get six [ __ ] she get six get your
own [ __ ] sex you [ __ ]
shut come on huh huh huh
[Music]
come on can I not batch cam it up
[Laughter]
[ __ ] a heart no sucking heart so get
some sex batch mean more money more
money more money
okay go get your girl some six come on
[Music]
no those people walking around outside
let it go or anything better
[Music]
okay activity
should be faster I just still take like
10 years I feel like I didn't do
anything I'm gonna get broke fast out I
can't even get the money fast enough
okay it's a time for these [ __ ]
Jesus gonna take like 10 years Oh suck
in the time off okay okay good good good
okay
[ __ ] hey more money in this [ __ ]
let's promo this [ __ ] up every day right
yeah okay
[Music]
no sweat [ __ ] sure I can't I need to
get money faster Khan [ __ ] come on
[ __ ] please kill me
[ __ ] [ __ ] faster faster
now we're rolling in money
Jenny get six
I got we had a slow start one hour down
it we're doing it now we are getting
tons of money and okay you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] to stress the house it came to
[ __ ] out these holes their holes are
probably [ __ ] pinkish [ __ ] okay Jesus
yes yes yeah how are you yeah great
please all right you [ __ ] any sings
easy-peasy done with that please kill me
[Music]
I'm on it give it a shot like I have a
choice like I have a chance any more
money
Cod [ __ ] 10,000 [ __ ] I can a staffer
anymore gals I guess it doesn't really
matter when I get it right
oh [ __ ]
that's what I need to start out [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] I need a nicotine patch
does an hour
my life you can't double up the animals
[ __ ] what am i doing
okay alright [ __ ] faster can I get that
running a lot of hands on ours [ __ ]
please kill you [ __ ] [ __ ] you give
it a shot all the e girls are making me
so proud okay
yes this is the one I need oh sorry how
to piggyback okay we're doing really
good
to get the k2 stressed out you [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay I'm done with sex
I'm actually a positive improvement on
these women's lives
you know I'm Sam payroll so I can ask ok
pension Christmas [ __ ] name mark Al's
marker just I don't want talent I would
hard workers that's what I want
oh [ __ ] a lot of money I'm gonna get a
lot of money after this holy [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] come on give me the money
maker come on agent Charlie two dollars
an hour
never never all right
hey you selected some of our more so I
made a deal with the owner of the best
part
the downside is well what's like without
a little get the [ __ ] in there but if I
exit you're like a hundred percent
escorts okay time to invest five hundred
six girls is that weather that crazy
like
looky then we gotta go ahead be sure
about that will do here why not
okay I think it's some people working
you know shiny I'll make that one girl
good last one the are or what's the
[ __ ] negative effect
just be careful will yet chlamydia
fuckin'-a and I'm [ __ ] heal her all
right you're you're just going to be our
[ __ ] not too bad at all
more money more money
okay come come little faster mm our hell
now my opinion [ __ ] okay here goes
nothing you don't have a choice will do
that's for another shut up let's get
lots of fans five hours
twenty-five style 22 toned [ __ ] that I
don't hear why not six dressed out is
you're on with these [ __ ] look it's
how do you fire girls in Sarah we've got
to be a way to fire them each time she's
camming kind of her cup size say
how can I help
I can't fire anyone
[ __ ] em no just fun max out the chicks
[Music]
yeah great I just need more money
[Music]
there's no like protection I can get for
them
it's condom
no sweat fuckin'-a well I have a choice
oh holy [ __ ] $60 an hour [ __ ] give it a
shot
give me some of that give me some of
that money [ __ ] dad you like that
me [ __ ] you out [ __ ] let me pour you
out there all [ __ ] up they're all like
so [ __ ] up okay
[ __ ] what's your call it's Caroline
into my headaches right what me see what
I can get
she's really [ __ ] up see what I can
get them antibiotics or something no
this is also hospital no no H is for
helicopter my bad come on let's go
[Music]
yes yes Oh
one of the most a [ __ ] condom okay oh
sure okay you need something hmm okay
we'll just see how it goes
can't can with hepatitis well okay then
[ __ ] let me get something here let's get
a little tough see what I could do here
5,000
but anymore please kill me
done with that here why not use your
base anything else
okey-dokey yes what we get some more
[ __ ] she's just getting to a [ __ ]
freak show flat-chest the gas frequent
364 an hour holy [ __ ] addicted addicted
now these ones [ __ ] suck you got any
more money Mar my dick half I like these
okay then [ __ ] can't [ __ ] hepatitis
course what I have a choice this is
turning out to be a disaster
this is like actually disaster well it's
almost over we're at 17
[ __ ] fans suck on this [ __ ] drinks
at deck dead
totally sucks out at the [ __ ] hour
oh [ __ ] oh boy
I don't think I have to pay them right
if I'm not like putting them to work
done with that
okay well what is this these are kind of
good
okay there we go
four dollars an hour I could do there
good luck bet or send you into the wolf
[Music]
what fuckin'-a give it a shot wow I'm
really [ __ ] up down this game they
should really be a way to like fire Oh
can't be the books no [ __ ] okay once
tricking up the [ __ ] storm
[Music]
I'm losing money now we'll do here why
not um hurry this up a little bit got
okay we got a couple browsers here
get some foods [ __ ] [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
he's young with that bow do shoot away
no line box
um hold on II think sed antibiotics okay
holy [ __ ] okay which ones can be cured
appreciate it okay okay bets this is a
[ __ ] disaster
I need to [ __ ] five thousand [ __ ] 10x
advertising
okay I got to put these [ __ ] guys to
work as well give it a shot leave it to
me okay then okay we got four cameras
and apparels pretty [ __ ] cheaper
element okay we're a date one date let's
get this money don't we go yeah you did
a great batch so uh when I get back to
work okay you too stressed out it's good
[Music]
the [ __ ] back in there can't can't can't
can't [ __ ] what are they gonna be
[ __ ] cure from STDs that's what I
want to know I should have never done
that it just goes to show how [ __ ] up
you can get yeah give you two sure
sounds okay just girl okay let's get
that money is get that money seven girls
that's a lot of women that is a lot of
women
as well champ champ champ champ champ
can't can't can't can't I bet I'd do a
lot better by that gets over again
no son be happy to write a fat [ __ ] out
of year okay
get some [ __ ] liquor all right
Sox again Faro give it a shot I thought
that's what they would get like York
let's say use available for Dodgers this
is the one I need
yes baby
come on [ __ ] get back in there three
days left Oh shet come on okay it's our
way neo nicotine patch girls awaiting
instructions
I can't have you [ __ ] smoking
everywhere self-understood right yes
what here why not just dress down
can't shoot with syphilis [ __ ]
what do we need talking get more liquor
I guess okay let's do this [ __ ] we
need that money and we need it now
God does suck down to just cured holy
[ __ ]
yes nice okay to trust out okay Graham
good this is email this game was a lot
more like [ __ ] micromanaging what I
thought it was so [ __ ] hard we get a
lot of [ __ ] money that's all I gotta
say [ __ ] about the prizes were fans gets
more fans our fans [ __ ] [ __ ] pan out Oh
Don I thank you please kill me please
kill me why not
crickets a [ __ ] bougie [ __ ] yeah I
got a thousand [ __ ] fans yeah bye-bye
Nana cry special Jenna cry dad is so
happy yeah ii got here okay with last
days i might as well send them all to
get that money okay time to get an STD
[ __ ] did it great dead again yep good
let's how are you out even more faster
bet yes faster yes yes yes yes good no
more more money more money
chef can't even like collect all the
money fast enough you guys are doing so
great I'm so proud of you come on Barry
comments
okay well you guys are making me proud
sound just just got there shed okay
Kimmy collect all the money on time
[Music]
can't can with AIDS why not hey beeps
teaching Oh exciting oh I can just
recruit more sure yes I can do that
you're the boss come on buddy who's
cured arrest date date
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I I could just swap
them out you're the boss yeah is it good
[Laughter]
okay
I hope I do okay okay we're fine yep no
more okay no more naturally let's make
some money this is what I am talking
about I'm dominating now it's easy once
they get STDs you just throw them to the
curb is that all that's my kind of woman
how did they die with the AIDS
leave it to me my pleasure
yeah I'd go ahead no sweat sure anything
else for me yeah yeah there - Sally
faster faster
I gotta get rid of these girls easy [ __ ]
watch out okay now we're talking
how were the aides girl you won't regret
it
hi come on [ __ ] s hell yeah can't get
done shuttle got chlamydia stress-free
[ __ ] these [ __ ] oh my god I'm making
so much money
I can't even skate I can't even get the
money fast enough
holy [ __ ]
okay go recruit more batches okay - Wow
sure thing baby you're the boss
about no wow
why's the model agency out of business
pikas i [ __ ] cut every single one of
them with like a s like [ __ ]
I really [ __ ] them up then I let's see
hey dead cam shows a lot of cam shows
okay 56 a lot of talent trick sumed
escorts oh my god
[ __ ] s course Lilian
Wow I [ __ ] dominated
good right shout the [ __ ] did you leave
the room with a clock running whose [ __ ]
I guess all that fan said all right
thanks for playing Sam or you can put it
up to you ah anyways thanks for watching
y'all thank ya